[Musique]
la grippe espagnole est la dernière grande
pandémie que nous avons vue tester de manière agressive les
systèmes de santé et dans le monde entier
[Musique]
nous avons des ventilateurs et la capacité d'
intuber les patients de manière à
pouvoir gérer de manière significative les
complications d'une maladie comme celle-ci  et
nous avons également la capacité de
désinfecter et de
traiter plus efficacement les personnes dans les espaces hospitaliers Je pense que
nous avons également la capacité de réagir
plus efficacement en tant qu'individus en raison
de nos niveaux et de notre
capacité d'hygiène généralement plus élevés pour nous laver les mains,
nous avons accès à des produits propres  arroser toutes
ces choses qui facilitent l'
assainissement des espaces dans lesquels nous vivons et dont
nous nous protégeons couverts 19 après la Première
Guerre mondiale les systèmes de santé étaient
déjà brisés les gens étaient affaiblis
et compromis en général à la suite
d'années d'un des plus  Des
guerres désastreuses que l'humanité ait jamais connues et à la
suite des allers-
retours entre les zones de guerre et leur domicile ou
des réfugiés retournant dans leur
pays d'origine, vous avez eu beaucoup de mouvements de
personnes capables de transmettre la maladie
plus efficacement que vous ne l'auriez pu à
l'extérieur  du contexte de la guerre
[Musique]
beaucoup de nos stratégies aujourd'hui ressembleraient
beaucoup à celles qui ont eu lieu
pendant la grippe espagnole, c'est-à-dire les
pratiques de distanciation sociale s'abstenir d'
aller à de grands événements pas de poignée de main se
laver fréquemment les mains tout cela
semblerait très  similaire au type de
réponses qui ont été fortement encouragées
en 1918 1919 les comparaisons avec la
grippe espagnole et l'inchoate 19 devraient
nous faire prendre conscience de la gravité potentielle
de cette épidémie si les gens n'ont pas accès
aux soins de santé les gens ont accès aux services
à la suite de cela  épidémie alors vous
savez évidemment que c'est vraiment un moment
où nous devons nous lever, prendre note et
prendre soin de ce problème de santé urgent